on est absolument pour une réforme de la
pac
on n'est pas complètement sûr à la
confédération paysanne qu'on parte
aujourd'hui en plein milieu des
négociations auxquelles on participe sur
une vraie réforme on a plutôt peur qu'on
parte sur des choses qui est avec des
modifications
j'allais dire à la marge alors que nous
estimons qu'il faudrait une vraie
réforme
on a quand même on perd chaque année de
nombreux paysans des paysans qui
n'hésite par terre un retraité qui sont
pas remplacés on a des gros problèmes de
revenus ça na pas avoir qu'avec la pâte
le produit les prix des produits
agricoles on à répondre à des enjeux
sociaux de remplacement des aviculteurs
de revenus et des enjeux
environnementaux et climatiques qui
offre qui appelle en fait à une vraie
réforme et on a peur que la réforme soit
pas à la hauteur des enjeux
nous on est comme un contre-feu réforme
là c'est pas compliqué aujourd'hui il ya
tout ce qu'on appelle les échos chimay
au régime il ya 40 % d'agriculteurs qui
les rend tout parler dans le ça veut
dire qu'il ya déjà avant de commencer
qu'après la culture et qui voulait
déposer une fois qu'on laisse aux
passants qui est volontairement grosso
modo dans l'année dans les zones
céréalières parce que il faut pas
confondre les l'élevage de plaine et les
céréaliers et les élevages qui sont
entre montagnes aujourd'hui nous nous
sommes vraiment compte revenir quand une
personne des gens qui ne rentre pas et
en plus ça sachant que à travers sa
laisse et rallieront ensuite le la
convergence il ya il ya s'il s'étend de
ça on a perdu ça soit trop tard et là on
nous reparle de perdre entre 76 et 80 au
retard
[Musique]
s'il ya eu autant de gens qui se sont
mobilisés en une semaine dix jours que
c'est pas pour le plaisir quoi c'est pas
pour le plaisir c'est que on perd une
grosse partie de notre revenu dans nokia
comme il est faible ça impacte
directement sur le revenu voilà et le
problème c'est que cet éco chine mais
même l'unité en train de s'apercevoir
qu'aujourd'hui dans les grandes zones
il est irréalisable moi je pense que ce
n'était pas que c'est pas enlever un
coup donné à l'autre il faut que toute
la culture de france à n'avoir que
puissent vivre de leur métier des cdd
des symboles et à sa chance en face à
quentin ça on perd ce qu'on appelle le
le le la souveraineté alimentaire d'une
part ça c'est sûr et certain qu'on me
l'interdît voilà on m'a raté des
produits en france dont on ne veut pas
du blé canadien dispose hâtez vous allez
avoir des légumes qui est marié ou du
téléphone de l'espagne ou de hollande
des détails pratiques
nous avons du blé dur qui va arriver
détendu qu'à l'interview aussi des de
certains pays de l'est et on ne renaît
on y donne des jeunes d'âge de
concurrence déloyale
la complication c'est que les aides sont
principalement attribuée à la surface et
donc il ya beaucoup de fermes avec des
plus petites surfaces aujourd'hui qu'ils
ont très peu d'elle c'est vraiment
quelque chose auquel nous on tient
absolument que les aides soient plus
pêcher vers chaque actif chaque
agriculteur plutôt que sur des grandes
surfaces et vous parler de souveraineté
alimentaire c'est tout à fait vrai par
exemple sur les fruits et légumes c'est
déjà le cas en france a aujourd'hui plus
de la moitié de ce qu'on consomme en
france en fruits et légumes et déjà
importés d'espagne et d'ailleurs c'est
ça les bras nous en tombent complètement
cette perte d'autonomie de souveraineté
sur ces produits là mais c'est justement
et c'est un bon exemple pour montrer que
la pac devrait être réformé c'est
justement des productions qui jusqu'à
aujourd'hui n'ont quasiment aucune
mesure de soutien de la part de la pac
non perçoit les échos régime
et puis d'autres rêves dans le second
pilier qui peuvent justement permettre
d'accompagner de motiver et de financer
du coup les des changements pratiques
qui sont des risques pour les
agriculteurs mais qu'on ne peut pas ne
pas prendre du tout et nous on aime suis
très inquiet là pour aller jusqu'à
jusqu'aux plus environnementale sur
l'agriculture biologique il ya des
engagements forts d'arriver à 25% des
salles françaises en bio on sait même
pas comment on va y arriver
s'il y avait des moyens dédiés derrière
et là aujourd'hui le compte y est pas
pour pouvoir y arriver
l'agriculture bio c'est malheureusement
un rayon de soleil qui joue pas ne va
pas durer le temps passera aujourd'hui
vous avez des pays de l'est qui on
demande beaucoup moins connue elle est
beaucoup moins de contrôle et qui arrive
en ce moment à fournir du bio à des prix
défiant toute concurrence
et je pense que malheureusement la
rigueur français d'ici deux trois ans
battre au fouet bave affaire va faire
face souci c'est que il sera obligé
acteurs bio sera obligée de poursuivre
son engagement d'accord en sachant que
avec toutes les charges qui en plus plus
de gasoil plutôt de travailler plus plus
de soucis sachant qu'il va peut-être
vais être obligé de vendre aux mêmes
puis au même prix que tinqueux que du
côté conventionnel